[Música]
la ofensiva contra El dominio del dólar
ha comenzado vale es verdad para ser
justos cada pocos años se anuncia el fin
del dólar como la moneda hegemónica a
nivel internacional su reemplazo por el
redmi chino llamémosle Joan y el
desastre que eso supondrá para la
economía norteamericana y luego al final
nada de nada esto nunca se cumple Pero
esta vez esta vez las cosas podrían ser
diferentes el dólar queridos amigos de
visualpolitik ha sido la base del
sistema financiero y comercial de todo
el mundo como mínimo desde los acuerdos
de bretton woods en 1944 han pasado Ya
prácticamente 8 décadas y sabéis que
ahora la urgencia para superar El
dominio del dólar parece cada vez más
evidente entre las dictaduras y las
economías emergentes estos países
empiezan a tener pavor a las
consecuencias que puede tener su
gigantesca dependencia hacia los
billetes del Tío Sam unos por las
posibles sanciones a las que pueden
terminar enfrentándose en esta línea las
sanciones contra Rusia y la congelación
de los activos de su Banco Central en
Estados Unidos y Europa ha puesto sobre
la mesa La amenaza que el dólar puede
suponer para la pasta de Los Tiranos y
luego los otros las economías emergentes
porque temen las consecuencias
económicas que puedan tener las
políticas de la reserva Federal por
ejemplo la rápida subida de tipos de
interés que se ha producido entre 2022 y
2023 Y por qué decimos esto Pues porque
las empresas de las economías emergentes
para fijar sus precios de exportación y
también para financiarse utilizan
fundamentalmente el dólar y si los tipos
suben o el dólar se revaloriza entonces
pueden tener un problema
[Música]
Pues bien estos son los dos motivos que
han hecho que la ofensiva contra el
dólar cobre nuevo brío por primera vez
parece haber una Clara voluntad política
para superar El dominio del billete
verde estamos viendo una erosión gradual
del dólar la imagen que surge es una de
un sistema monetario multipolar
Maximiliano castelli jefe de estrategia
para los mercados soberanos globales de
vs ahora bien Hasta qué punto está la
hegemonía del dólar en peligro será el
yuan su nueva alternativa Existe alguna
divisa que pueda hacer temblar los
cimientos financieros del Tío Sam Qué
consecuencias puede tener esta campaña
Pues bien aquí en visualpolitik vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas no
adelantes acontecimientos y prestad
mucha atención
[Aplausos]
Pero antes una pregunta sabes todo lo
que te estás perdiendo por no usar
surfshark lo más importante Por supuesto
la seguridad al navegar por internet
surfsharp te protege cifrando tu
actividad para que nadie pueda rastrear
ni robar tus datos bloquea anuncios y
malware con Clean web y protege tus
cuentas de correo electrónico con
surfshark alert notificándote si se
filtra tu información personal pero
espera porque aún hay más surfshark es
la primera VPN comercial con servidores
en más de 100 países distintos lo que
significa que puedes abrir a golpe de
clic un nuevo Universo de contenidos
restringidos Según tu ubicación además
con una misma cuenta podrá registrar
todos los dispositivos que quieras sin
límite la tablet tu Smartphone la Smart
TV el portátil todos y muy importante
ahora que no nos ve nadie esto en la
práctica significa que puedes compartir
la cuenta con tus mejores amigos para
cuando si cada uno unos pocos céntimos
al mes pero lo mejor de todo por ser
parte de la comunidad visualpolitik
podrás disfrutar de tres meses extra
totalmente gratis usando el código
politic acabado en K y dicho esto
continuemos con nuestro vídeo de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
después de años de especulación da la
sensación de que ahora sí el yuan está
dando un paso adelante para acabar con
El dominio mundial del dólar por ejemplo
la cuota del yuán en la financiación del
comercio mundial sea más que duplicado
desde la invasión rusa de Ucrania Por
qué pues en gran medida porque Rusia
está utilizando el yuan para intentar
superar las sanciones occidentales
fijaos no hay duda de que los rusos han
visto obligados a desdolarizar y también
de segurorizar su comercio hay pruebas
de que Rusia en particular está haciendo
mayor uso del yuan y también está claro
que los chinos y otros están buscando
oportunidades para ampliar el uso del
yuan en el acuerdo comercial bratzeth
economista del departamento del tesoro
de los Estados Unidos y ex asesor de la
oficina comercial de Estados Unidos para
que os hagáis una idea el comercio entre
Rusia y China superó los 185 mil
millones de dólares en 2022 y en 2023
quedará atrás la Barrera de los 200.000
millones lo más interesante de todo esto
que las empresas rusas ya están pagando
la mayoría de sus importaciones chinas
en yuanes Y eso eso no es todo los
intercambios en yuanes en la se han
disparado y los bancos excluidos del
Swift ahora utilizan el cips el sistema
chino de pagos interbancarios
fronterizos y aún más Vladimir Putin ha
dicho que quiere usar la moneda china no
solo para comerciar con china sino
también como una forma de pago para el
comercio ruso con Asia África y América
Latina de hecho según ha confirmado el
viceprimer ministro ruso Alexander noval
y este país ya liquida más acuerdos
comerciales en yuanes que en dólares
Claro que no solo hablamos de Rusia
otros países como Arabia saudí
bangladesh India Argentina Pakistán Irak
o Bolivia han empezado o parecen estar
cerca de hacerlo a negociar y realizar
sus intercambios comerciales con china
directamente yuanes y sí es posible que
estemos hablando también de parte del
comercio de crudo saudí que es
exactamente lo que explica noticias como
esta 9 de diciembre de 2022 si pide que
el comercio de petróleos hagan yuanes en
la Cumbre del Golfo en riad en esta
misma línea el 29 de marzo China y
Brasil anunciaron planes concretos para
operar con sus propias monedas y dejar
el dólar de Estados Unidos de lado en
sus intercambios comerciales y aún más
conforme a estos mismos planes Brasil
permitirá a todos los países
sudamericanos liquidar sus acuerdos
comerciales en yuanes de hecho su
presidente Pues no ha podido ser más
claro atentos
que todos sus países estén obligados
incluso una empresa francesa como la
petrolera y energética total completó a
finales de marzo su primer intercambio
de gas natural licuado en yuanes con la
china National of Shore o incorporation
el intercambio consistió en 65.000
toneladas de gas natural licuado
extraído en emiratos árabes Unidos y
hablando de emiratos la India parece
estar precisamente utilizando los dirham
seminaties en muchos de sus acuerdos con
Rusia
así que ya lo veis estamos ante todo Una
ofensiva para desbancar al billete verde
o al menos para reducir su enorme peso
internacional a ver estrictamente esto
pues no es algo nuevo china lleva
intentando internacionalizar el yuan
desde la crisis financiera del 2008 aquí
en visualpolitik ya os contamos como A
mediados del 2017 nació el petrol para
comerciar petróleo entre Rusia y China
algo que como acabamos de ver ahora se
ha generalizado a la mayor parte del
entre estos dos países pero sea como sea
el caso es que esta operación ha cobrado
nuevo brillo como veis China y otros
países quieren evitar a toda Costa que
llegado el momento Estados Unidos pueda
congelar sus reservas extranjeras como
ha hecho con Rusia o bloquear sus
economías impidiéndoles el comercio en
dólares y queridos amigos amigas eso es
eso es exactamente lo que ha vuelto a
poner de nuevo este tema en la agenda La
pregunta es realmente podría el yuan
desbancar O al menos competir con el
dólar decidirán los Países Árabes pasar
del petrodólar al petrol nacerá un nuevo
mercado absorbe yuanes para comerciar e
invertir con esta divisa a lo largo y
ancho del mundo a la imagen y semejanza
del mercado del euro dólar pues atentos
[Música]
dólar versus Joan el desenlace
queridos amigos amigas el dólar es tan
pero que tan importante en el sistema
monetario internacional que incluso en
comparación hace que el peso económico
de Estados Unidos parezca muy poco
relevante fijaos en esta gráfica como
veis mientras que Estados Unidos supone
aproximadamente el 24% del pib mundial y
en torno al 15% del comercio el dólar es
hegemónico casi el 60% de las reservas
extranjeras y la mitad de toda la
financiación internacional y las
transacciones comerciales utilizan esta
divisa si hablamos de finanzas y Divisas
está claro que hoy por hoy hablamos
sobre todo del dólar y sí es verdad
puede que lo hayas escuchado desde el
año 2000 la proporción de las reservas
internacionales mantenidas en dólares se
han reducido de aproximadamente un 70% A
menos del 60 Esto es algo a lo que
siempre aluden los catastrofistas sobre
el futuro de los billetes del Tío Sam
sin embargo Espero que un momento porque
este dato en modo tiene trampa
[Música]
Y es que veréis tiene trampa primero
porque las reservas internacionales se
han multiplicado por cuatro Así que hoy
la cantidad de reservas en dólares es
muchísimo mayor que nunca antes y
segundo porque los principales
beneficiarios de Esta caída en cuota de
Mercado han sido además de la divisa
china las monedas de Canadá Australia
Suecia Corea del Sur y Singapur Pues
bien todos estos países mantienen líneas
de intercambio de dólares con la reserva
Federal es decir esto significa que en
la práctica No ya es que estos países
sean estrechos aliados de Estados Unidos
sino que además sus Divisas tienen casi
total convertibilidad con el billete
verde y eso es precisamente lo que hace
que muchas instituciones no tengan
problema en utilizarlas En otras
palabras que lo miremos por donde lo
miremos El dominio del dólar sigue
siendo aplastantemente abrumador es la
gran divisa internacional y sí ya sé lo
que muchos queréis que os diga que esto
está a punto de cambiar por completo que
los chinos les están ganando el pulso a
los norteamericanos que Shanghai vencerá
a Wall Street pues lo siento pero parece
difícil que eso ocurra
con los datos en la mano no parece que
hoy por hoy el yuan representante un
gran riesgo Sí vale es prácticamente
seguro que la cuota de Mercado del yuan
crecerá en los próximos años eso es de
cajón china cada vez pesa más en la
economía internacional sin embargo
fijaos en marzo de 2023 y pese a muchos
años de esfuerzo el yuan apenas
representó el 2,4% de los pagos
internacionales canalizados por el
sistema Swift que es el sistema líder en
todo el mundo el dólar por su parte
representó más del 40% de todas las
transacciones pero para verlo más
claramente
echemos un vistazo al caso por ejemplo
de Corea del Sur china es de largo su
mayor socio comercial es su mayor
proveedor y al mismo tiempo también su
mayor Pues bien el peso del yuan en los
intercambios de estos dos países ha
crecido paso del 0%, antes de 2008 a
casi el 6% en 2020 que evidentemente no
es más que eso un 6%. para que os hagáis
una idea en las exportaciones de Corea
del Sur a China que no tienen nada que
ver con Estados Unidos el dólar sigue
siendo la moneda predominante en 2020 el
87% de todas estas operaciones se
seguían haciendo en dólares y respecto a
las reservas internacionales qué queréis
que os diga Más de lo mismo
[Música]
en este caso la cuota del billete verde
es del 58% frente a tan solo el 2,7 de
su adversario Y sí ya Lo acabamos de
decir la cuota de Mercado del yuan en el
comercio mundial Seguro seguro que va a
crecer Durante los próximos años Aunque
Bueno eso es algo que ya está ocurriendo
fijaos la participación de la
financiación del comercio se duplica
desde el inicio de la Guerra de Ucrania
ojo que sin embargo una cosa es
comerciar en una divisa y otra muy
diferente es estar dispuesto a guardar
tu dinero en esa misma divisa y aquí los
Estados Unidos de América tienen mucha
ventaja concretamente podemos destacar
tres grandes ventajas primero bueno son
los mercados amigo
[Música]
la superpotencia norteamericana tiene
los mercados de capitales más grandes y
líquidos de todo el planeta para los
inversores extranjeros es muy fácil
colocar allí sus dólares para sacar
rentabilidad con ellos acciones deuda
del gobierno fondos de todo tipo en
Estados Unidos puedes colocar mover O
sacar prácticamente todos los dólares
que quieras sin que eso suponga ningún
problema ni el mercado se venga abajo es
demasiado grande Esto es algo que no
ocurre en China y sabéis que en cierto
modo esto nos puede recordar al caso del
euro el euro es la divisa de un
gigantesco bloque económico y desde su
nacimiento ha cobrado bastante
relevancia internacional pero no la
suficiente para competir con el dólar sí
tiene mucho peso en las transacciones
comerciales pero en el resto de
parámetros Esta divisa es mucho más
pequeña que el billete verde y ojo
porque en el caso de China no se trata
solo de que los mercados financieros de
este país sean mucho más pequeños Es que
la seguridad jurídica tampoco es
equivalente esta sería la segunda
ventaja
Y es que a ver Sé honesto Con qué estás
más tranquilo con dólares en el bolsillo
o con yuanes Seguro seguro que los que
nos estáis viendo desde América Latina
yo creo que lo tenéis muy claro pues
exactamente la misma impresión tienen
por ejemplo los Países Árabes nos quepa
la menor duda y luego para colmo como
tercera gran ventaja para Estados Unidos
es que China tiene un montón de
controles de capitales es decir que no
puedes manejar convertir o sacar del
país el dinero libremente Y
evidentemente eso hace que difícilmente
te plantees ahorrar en yuanes de hecho
uno de los motivos por los que existen
estos controles de capital es para
evitar que los propios chinos saquen
masivamente sus ahorros del país que es
exactamente lo que ocurrió entre los
años 2014 y 2016 cuando se abrió un poco
la mano no lo recordáis pues Mirad las
salidas de capitales de China aumentan
hasta un millón de dólares
Aproximadamente en 2015 la consecuencia
el gobierno
volvió a echar el cierre 22 de diciembre
de 2017 China endurece la inversión en
el extranjero para reducir los riesgos
Así que lo siento pero no no parece
probable que a la hora de la verdad el
yuan sea una alternativa real ahora bien
quiere decir todo esto que el dólar
simplemente nunca tendrá rival pues nada
más lejos de la realidad atentos
[Música]
viendo fuerzas
[Aplausos]
vale No no parece que el yoanchi no
pueda ganarle el pulso al Dólar sí se
hará más importante y más visible pero
no parece la mejor opción para superar
al Tío Sam y sabéis que los adversarios
de Estados Unidos lo saben y es aquí
donde surge una jugada La gran jugada
que tienen en mente en marzo de 2023 El
vicepresidente de la duma estatal la
cámara de diputados de Rusia Alexander
babacof dijo que Rusia está liderando el
desarrollo de una nueva moneda para
utilizarla en el comercio
transfronterizo de los brics ya sabéis
Brasil Rusia India China y Sudáfrica un
grupo que representa más del 40% de toda
la población mundial y casi un tercio de
toda la economía del planeta poca broma
un grupo al que ahora países como Arabia
saudí o Irán podrían querer sumarse Pues
bien la pregunta es qué pasaría si tal y
como advertía el vicepresidente de la
duma este grupo lanzará una moneda y si
esta divisa además estuviera respaldada
por oro y otros metales con valor Como
por ejemplo las tierras raras
pues ojo porque parece que por aquí van
los tiros además es que los brics son lo
suficientemente Grandes como para
arrastrar a otros países a comerciar con
su nueva divisa desde Tailandia
kazajistán pasando por media áfrica o
América Latina esto quiere decir que
fácilmente podría ser una moneda
utilizada para las transacciones
internacionales de países que
representan el 40 o el 50% del pib
mundial y no solo eso al estar
respaldado su valor por activos reales y
carecer de controles de capital también
podría crearse un mercado financiero que
permitiera que se utilizara como
reservas o depósito de valor que es lo
que veíamos que el yuan no era capaz de
lograr ojo Eso no resolvería todos los
problemas Habría que ver quién manda
sobre esta divisa si se constituye un
Banco Central supranacional o si es
factible poner de acuerdo a tantos
países con regímenes bueno tampoco
habituados a la transparencia y a
respetar las normas pero es una
posibilidad que está sobre la mesa y de
hecho ni siquiera haría falta que
derrotara el dólar perfectamente
podríamos estar ante el nacimiento de un
nuevo sistema monetario mucho más
multipolar al menos este Parece ser el
objetivo de sus promotores Pero qué pasa
con los Estados Unidos le preocupa
realmente este movimiento pues presta
mucha pero que mucha atención
el fin de la hegemonía unipolar
querida comunidad es muy probable sea la
moneda de los bricks o cualquier otra es
muy probable que antes o después el
dólar sea superado o como mínimo que
encuentre un rival capaz de hacerle
sombra es decir que lo que una vez se
calificó como el privilegio exorbitante
del dólar llegará a su fin y aún más es
muy posible que ese momento no esté
demasiado lejos el empuje asiático ha
hecho que la economía de Estados Unidos
cada vez tenga menos peso en la economía
mundial del 40% del pib Global en los
años 60 al entorno del 24% hoy en día y
ojo que en términos monetarios el tamaño
es importante y es que veréis para que
el dólar continúe siendo la gran moneda
de Reserva la economía de Estados Unidos
tiene que suministrarle al resto del
mundo Cada vez más y más dólares y
también más y más activos nominados en
dólares Pues bien esas son las
operaciones que financian alimentan e
incluso promueven la deuda del Gobierno
Federal y el déficit comercial crónico
que sufre este país y aquí es donde hay
una importante división de opiniones
para unos Estados Unidos Ha logrado
hacer de las finanzas un sector
hiperproductivo cuya producción casi que
debería formar parte de la balanza
comercial es decir Estados Unidos
exporta bienes servicios y también
productos financieros productos que a su
vez han financiado el enorme desarrollo
tecnológico de este país silicon Valley
Pues eso para otros en cambio todo esto
en realidad podría ser una [__] Por
qué Pues porque la demanda mundial del
dólar hace que su valor sea más alto del
que debería ser o que castiga la
producción local al encarecer los
productos en dólares disminuye la
competitividad de su industria y reduce
los empleos industriales que además
suelen estar muy bien pagados eso es lo
que defiende por ejemplo Jared Bernstein
Y quién es este tipo me diréis pues ni
más ni menos que el jefe del Consejo de
accesorios económicos de la
Administración biden el economista jefe
de la caza Blanca vamos que aún
cualquiera no es
[Música]
Pues bien según esta perspectiva el
nacimiento de otra gran divisa no haría
temblar El poder del dólar sobre todo en
términos absolutos pero sí que
permitiría aliviar la fuerte presión que
existe sobre esta divisa de esta forma
Se podrían reducir algunos Grandes
desequilibrios como el déficit comercial
y se podría frenar la sobrevaloración
relativa que según dicen tanto está
castigando mucho la competitividad de
las empresas industriales de este país
pero sea como sea y estemos o no de
acuerdo hay una cosa cierta no todo el
mundo está tan contento con la hegemonía
del dólar a escala mundial en otras
palabras que quizás en Washington no
estén tan preocupados por su enorme peso
económico por sus mercados financieros y
por la seguridad jurídica seguramente el
dólar siga siendo una moneda líder pero
que pueda existir otra divisa que la
acompañe Pues de entrada a la
administración biden no parece que esto
sea algo que les preocupe excesivamente
más bien ya lo habéis visto hasta todo
lo contrario La pregunta es tienen razón
Estados Unidos saldría ganando o
perdiendo con esta nueva moneda
alternativa realmente surgirá Una divisa
que sea capaz de doblegar El poder del
dólar confiarías tus ahorros a una
divisa liderada por China y Rusia
déjanos tus impresiones en los
comentarios y hablamos debate recordad
que con el código politik acabado en K
podéis disfrutar de tres meses extra
totalmente gratis con surfshark el link
como siempre abajo en la descripción y
ahora si este vídeo te resulta
interesante No olvides darle al botón de
like y suscribirte a visualpolitik si es
que aún no lo has hecho una vez más
Muchas gracias por estar ahí un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]